I'm going to take a moment getting around to the answer to this question,
because there is so many different mistakes one can make right here.
Let's explore some of the incorrect options before we arrive at
the right answer.
A simple idea might be to repeat the code that we saw in
the car function right here in the Van subclass constructor.
Since there's so little of it.
Notice this would have the effect of creating a loc property on every instance.
And that loc property would point to the number in question.
But that's not exactly what we want if it forces us to repeat the same code in
two different places.
But this poses a few issues.
For one, if you ever change how instantiation works,
you would have to remember to change both places.
Furthermore, you can tell that the logic here is quite simple, but
that's just for the purpose of our example.
In most classes,
there's going to be a lot more code in a super class constructor.
You would have to repeat in the subclass.
So we have a bit of a puzzle on our hands.
We'd really like to simply run the Car function in the middle of
the Van function.
But in such a way that it modifies the new van instance that's being created.
You might suppose we could simply call car the way you normally do
with the keyword new in front of it.
But this is problematic for a couple of reasons.
What would you expect the effect of this technique to
be on your in-memory model?
Take a moment to imagine how this code would play out when it's
actually running.
For reference, here is the in memory model that we're starting to build up.
The answer is that if we tried to call the Car function with the keyword new,
it's going to have the effect of creating another new instance object,
in addition to the one that got created in Rhonda JS,
as a result of calling new van.